(impact de la balle)
- C'est un son distinctif,
le contact du bâton avec
la balle, puis les cris de joie
et d'admiration.
Lorsque l'étouffante chaleur
indienne s'estompe en fin
de journée, des milliers
de jeunes jouent au cricket,
des bidonvilles aux plages
pittoresques.
Les écoles sont fermées
en raison de la pandémie.
Muhammad en profite
pour passer encore plus temps
sur ce terrain.
Pour des milliers de jeunes
Indiens, le cricket est devenu
un refuge pour échapper
aux horreurs de la deuxième
vague qui terrasse le pays.
Imanchu ne pense qu'à retrouver
ses amis ici chaque jour, des
instants volés de pur bonheur.
En Inde, oû la foi et
les dissensions religieuses
façonnent la vie,
on dit que le cricket est
la religion officieuse du pays.
Les jeunes passionnés
les plus fortunés peuvent
pratiquer leur sport favori
dans des centres de formation.
Shovati fait partie de
cette académie de Lucknow
depuis deux ans. Il ne vit que
pour s'améliorer et il rêve
de représenter son pays sur
la scène internationale un jour.
Son bâton est comme une épée.
Avec elle, il se sent
invincible.
Motivation ultime :
un grand nombre de jeunes
Indiens rêvent de sortir de
la pauvreté grâce au cricket.
L'entraîneur Vivay n'a que
22 ans. Il espère encore
atteindre la prestigieuse ligue
professionnelle indienne.
La Indian Premier League est
la sixième ligue sportive
la plus puissante de la planète
après la NFL et les grandes
ligues de soccer en Europe.
La IPL devait offrir une
distraction, des moments
quotidiens de répit pendant
la pandémie, mais les activités
ont été suspendues le 4 mai.
De plus en plus d'Indiens
s'opposaient à la tenue
du tournoi.
"La ligue reprendra plus tard,
dit-il. iIl est plus important
de sauver notre pays et
nos citoyens en ce moment."
Pandémie ou pas, le cricket
continue de susciter
la ferveur en Inde.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, L